genius brain listeners are you wasting
money on subscriptions well guess what
if you had rocket money you wouldn't be
doing that because rocket money would
take care of all your useless
subscriptions for you get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com genius seriously it
could save you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com genius to cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com genius
wishing for that I'm wishing that the
next project that you do that you come
out as an amazing actor so you could
talk that [ __ ] [ __ ] because right now
your foundation is shaky that's why
people every time you tweet something
about representation people see through
it now they go this is not about
representation this is about you so the
first thing they want to tell you to do
is shut the [ __ ] up just be quiet yeah
let your artwork let your work show who
you are you can do that dude you can
[ __ ] do it you can let your work
represent in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast it
was a lovely Thanksgiving a big old
break and a lot of things have happened
since and now we're here in Tampa we
have Ed park on the podcast today what's
up cheers my friend air cheers
clink yes
uh we have not listen
we originally want to talk about Black
Panther but I haven't seen black panther
yet oh I haven't seen it yet
um thought twice
uh I saw uh [ __ ] what did I just say
Black Adam I got him which I was telling
Ed he doesn't have to see because Black
Adam was just like
every other superhero film that just
kind of inundates you with a lot of like
VFX amazing VFX by the way yeah like
black Adam's VFX in terms of like the
fight scenes and like what they did with
it was pretty [ __ ] amazing but kind
of same Trope with like the whole thing
of
they just inundate you with so much
visual [ __ ] they don't care about the
the build up the story and kind of
making things count right let me guess
the plot is in the beginning the rock is
a badass and then he becomes a badass
right and then someone challenges him
and he's a badass and then it ends and
he's a [ __ ] badass yeah right okay
it's it's really the I'll tell you this
though it was like some of the Rock's
best acting you know um really really
yeah he didn't have much lines he didn't
say much but he played like this very
cool subtle character right which I
thought he did a really great job in but
the first scene where you see Black Adam
appear he's just kicking [ __ ] ass it
was amazing but then that would have
felt better if you led up to it it just
happened right right in the first 10
minutes it just happened and Black Adam
appears and then you find out his whole
story in the last like 20 minutes of the
film
so that's right so do you want like wait
till the end if you want to start
instead of progressing and opening up a
story exactly so you figure out why he
is the way he is right at the end it's
like wait hold on if you would have told
us a little bit about this that we could
have seen his story arc why he's doing
these things why he's so amazing and it
was just okay I just watched it for
enter I turned off my brain like I did
with love and thunder so maybe like it
was an editing thing right if there
might be a re-edit of it or something
maybe huh and then they just tossed the
way that it was playing out I don't know
oh it could have been yeah I'm pretty
sure if they flipped out the structure
of the film it would have been a lot
better because you know a lot of his
story that he was talking about where he
was talking about his son how he got his
powers had a lot to do with
and just like all these other films
there's always one actor that [ __ ]
kills it just like in Shang Chi right it
was Tony lung and this one it was Pierce
Brosnan Pierce brosno he [ __ ] killed
it dude he was the [ __ ] yeah he's well
um if you guys don't know too uh my bond
growing up yeah he was the one my first
Recollections being the 80s Bond I guess
but I see I don't even know his name
yeah ours was Pierce Brosnan with the
one with Halle Berry and everything
we'll find a [ __ ] yeah but um
yeah I don't care if you like so well
here's the thing if there is is there
even anything to spoil except the fact
that he's just gonna be a badass
throughout the homework not really
you're not going to really care about
anything in the film and I think like
this is you know one of the things I I
want to talk about is just kind of I
don't know what the trajectory of a lot
of these like Marvel and DC films like
what their what they plan to do next
right because at this point this past
like year or so has been pretty
disappointing right not not everything
there's there's been a lot of great TV
shows there was Loki there was a wand
division but these are the TV series but
the film is starting to like I'm
actually not excited to see these films
anymore yeah so we're talking about
phase four in general right yeah outside
of the a lot of Disney plus series
um there's a there's some misses with
some Disney plus stuff like I didn't
like Moon Knight
um it was but then it was its own
self-contained story like it had nothing
to do almost with MCU yeah which is
great crazy yeah
um but the MCU movies
it's kind of hard to admit this to
myself but look you know I'm in my 30s
now
you know so uh I was watching I mean I
grew up with Marvel [ __ ] like from the
90s and stuff but
I don't know if it's just getting older
but then getting into phase four I
remember I was at home I was like let me
put on spider went Spider-Man no wait uh
no way home yeah
wow I it wasn't back as I remembered it
I think it was just a hype in the
theater
yeah I was seeing certain films that you
watched too like the hype definitely
plays a a huge role into it right I
think for me Spider-Man no way home was
really good at developing these oh [ __ ]
moments right right which I haven't felt
in a lot of Marvel films lately
especially when it came to ant made
dying yeah which I thought was like you
know it was like a chef's kiss moment it
was just whoa this is it it matters yeah
oh it's like she represents the death of
um Uncle Ben yeah you know in this
universe and it was a really great way
to expand on opening your mind towards
this Universal stuff happening well
Multiverse stuff happening yeah
but
um
I'm just kind of sit there and watch
like yeah what's going off and you're
just like
should I even care anymore like I I
might not invest you know was I to
invested and I find myself just stepping
out of it and like
I know I'm watching it because I have
been watching it yeah yeah yeah I'm
watching these things well you know for
me too and I've talked about this before
the one of the biggest reasons why I
really really enjoyed Marvel films is
because when we were kids we had Lou
Ferrigno as the Hulk
so this was what we had yeah we had um
Adam West as Batman right you know
Shazam you know pop pow it was like
corny [ __ ] yeah this is this is what we
had right and um so when we get to see
technology progressed it actually
allowed for you know the film to catch
up with our imagination which was pretty
[ __ ] insane right but just like
anything that you get like there's a
certain amount there's a certain point
where it sensory overload where we're so
kind of used to this yeah we expect this
now right so now that the whole awe and
the explosions are great it's great for
children
um right like little kids will like it
well speaking on that though if you
showed a kid Jurassic Park you will
never be as mesmerized as we were when
we first saw Jurassic Park like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] dinosaur
and it holds up to this day it's better
than the Jurassic World Series 100 yeah
you know
um and that's a whole nother CGI uh
discussion but like
yeah that's the thing like because the a
lot of kids
um just grew up in CJ has been around
you know they'll watch Toy Story one
like what is this [ __ ] which is funny
because the way I remember Toy Story one
was very different from what I saw I was
like wow this is interesting yeah yeah
and the story is still great but then
when we were younger and we saw stuff
like that or Like A Bug's Life or some
[ __ ] right it was some Next Level [ __ ]
right and so to us it was absolutely
amazing we hadn't seen something like
this before yeah so now we're getting a
little taste of this like these younger
kids are going to get with whatever
comes out in the future as adults and I
think like Marvel has to kind of shift
now to like okay we're not getting away
with all the explosions and just the
cool fighting now we have to go back
into character development we have to go
back in the story we have to do all this
stuff again that traditional film does
which by the way you know if you guys
have heard of this and you know people
have been asking me to talk about this
and I I genuinely didn't want to talk
about it because everybody thinks I
[ __ ] hate this guy right
right and I'm always gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt first just because
you know he's an Asian dude that's an
actor he's a huge face you know
literally and figuratively
roasted just kidding I have to now
because you guys are making me do this
but you know in this in this whole scene
right so obviously there's something
that blew up over like Twitter and stuff
and
I didn't know what it was about right it
was something about Quentin Tarantino
and if you read the headline it's
basically saying that Quentin Tarantino
says that Marvel uh film actors aren't
uh act real actors right and obviously
they're being very clickbaity and you
know when I first read this [ __ ] I'm
like what the [ __ ] did Tarantino say
again right but then again I kind of
know or we all know simulu's tendency to
kind of just you know make everything
such a huge [ __ ] deal so I'm like
okay maybe these two [ __ ] whiny
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] are both
these guys talking about yeah
so by the way I love Tarantino yeah but
you can be whiny he could be very
[ __ ] whiny and he looks like a troll
face yeah like I love Tarantino it's
some of my favorite films are from him
so
I see this interview from two bears one
cave uh with Tom Segura and he's
interviewing he's asking about Marvel
films and the way that these articles
were first written right and by the way
a majority of the articles that were
written were actually against simulu and
what he said and so I thought Tarantino
said something specifically against like
Shang Chi he wasn't even a part of the
[ __ ] conversation
this [ __ ] hot he can
scotched right the [ __ ] into something
that had nothing to do with him a b c
you're way out of this conversation and
that's essentially what the internet was
saying it's like where the [ __ ] did you
come from yeah like nobody is even
asking you about this [ __ ] why did and
that's the thing I think a lot of people
have an issue with him about it's like
he somehow turns every single thing into
like what about me what about me and
it's in the guise of like Asian
positivity it's not really about like oh
this is how we feel as Asian people like
number one I never ask you to represent
me
I don't understand where he kind of got
this bravado of like I'm the Exemplar
example of what Asian men should be see
we could be different we're attractive
who asked you so it's like you know what
what we're trying to ask him is can you
just preface your tweets with like in my
personal
opinion yeah in the opinion of one human
being it was just a weird thing for him
to do and I think majority of the people
online were like and it kind of sucks
for him right because he just got this
huge thing with Chang Chi he did this
whole huge Marvel film it grossed big
numbers yeah and then the moment he
tweets this stupid [ __ ] people are like
dude shut the [ __ ] up and he's tweeting
about like what is he saying like that
he is a movie star yes oh
oh excuse me that's okay can I interject
something I am a movie star
that's essentially what the three says
[Laughter]
problem right
the thing is like he's been doing such a
good job in kind of fooling the public
into believing that his main goal is to
make sure that Asian people are having a
come up because not Asian people it's
you you're trying to shed Light On You
by using this as a catalyst to make
yourself look good but David don't you
understand
simu is Asian people
she is all Asian people dude and look
you know I'm kind of curious to what
people think about this too and I you
know when I read the comments a majority
of the comments are mirroring what I'm
I'm saying or what I have said in the
past right like I said I don't know this
guy personally but if if we are to
believe that he is who he says he is on
these tweets or what he puts out in the
public as a Reddit in cell
I'm like dude do a better job of lying
to the public right because at this
point it's not okay I gotta stand up for
Asians it's how do I insert myself in
this place here because I gotta make
sure that people know I'm a star and
that's what it feels like maybe it's not
but yeah if it's not the case he's not
doing a very good job of it so I mean
like bro with all this Twitter [ __ ]
going on like seriously if Twitter
[ __ ] shut down tomorrow
not only just like not only just like
who are a lot of people out there in
that Twitter verse then right it's so
it's like is are you in this [ __ ]
Echo chamber
no of your own thoughts and we also said
too like you know just on an advice tip
it's like bro who are your friends
around you that that can tell you to
shut the [ __ ] up like you need a couple
of those friends to be like hey
buddy nobody's no you're you're not in
this conversation right now yeah you
shut the mouse yeah shut the mouse man
because I don't even think he actually
saw the clip because if he did he
wouldn't have said what he said so like
I don't want to misquel the guy right
yeah so I haven't heard it so it's okay
to put it on let me show you what uh
simu said and then you I'll show you the
clip okay so this is his tweet if the
only Gatekeepers to the movie to movie
stardom came from Tarantino and Scorsese
I would never have had the opportunity
to lead a 400 million plus movie
uh congratulations so once again to him
I am in awe of their filmmaking genius
they are Transcendent art tours okay yes
I call [ __ ] on that the only reason
why I say [ __ ] is because you
clearly haven't seen anything that
they've done because you never would
have tweeted this uh
but they don't get to Point their nose
at me or anyone
that's what kind of got him [ __ ]
how about you scorses is like 85 years
old man like he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you
no movie studio is or ever will be
perfect but I'm proud to work with one
that has made sustained efforts to
improve diversity on screen by creating
Heroes that Empower and inspire people
of all communities everywhere that's
just Oscar speech I love the Golden Age
2 but if but it was white as hell once
again made it about race and the reason
why he got ripped because of this is
like do you know who you're talking
about right now
people were calling him on his [ __ ]
he goes wait you say you love Scorsese
and Tarantino and you're saying that
they're the ones that are whitewashing
Hollywood
um I don't think these are the directors
you're talking about right now yeah
Tarantino are you talking about [ __ ]
kill Bill yeah uh uh Pulp Fiction
Reservoir Dogs [ __ ] Jackie Brown
Jackie Brown is so underrated I think
he's one of those actors that doesn't
watch film
sleep like if you say you say that you
respect them that they're these auteurs
how do you not know their lineage of
film to go ahead and write this tweet
out everybody on their Amir is calling
his [ __ ] now they're like hold on
tarantina first of all let me I mean I
mean like just the issue at hand I love
the golden age but it was white as hell
you know imagine if Tarantino says or
Wu-Tang Clan says I love the Shaw
Brothers I love Hong Kong action but
it's Asian as hell what the [ __ ] bro
like seriously come on man such a bad
[ __ ] cake like yes you can be racist
against white people bro
like come on the double standard though
you know if you're not gonna want to
hear that on your end you probably
shouldn't say it out of your own mouth
right and do you not remember I don't
know one of the most famous [ __ ]
directors of all time specifically out
of Korea ponjuno giving huge credit to
who
yeah because Tarantino legit was singing
pong Juno's Praises talking about some
of the films that he has made has been
some of the best pieces of artwork that
he has ever seen in his life yeah that
was what Tarantino was saying he was
championing one of the biggest [ __ ]
Asian names as a director in a Hollywood
in his Oscar speech for winning Best
Director he gave it up to them and here
you are on Twitter excuse me excuse me
I'm a movie star and you guys are white
that's why I'm saying that's why I was a
little confused when I read his tweet I
was like oh you are one of those people
that don't watch film well I mean like
what is he projecting then like or I
don't know not only is it is he trying
to project that how is the in taking
their films and being so upset so maybe
we should listen to the clip here's
here's the thing okay let's watch let's
watch this two bears one cave because I
I have a lot more thoughts about this
this [ __ ] fantastic guy yeah
here we go
so this is the clip that you guys are
going to hear
um or you will see if you're watching
this uh on YouTube but so Quentin
Tarantino basically came on two bears 1K
with Tom Segura and this is the clip
that everybody is taking from that
they're not really necessarily
misquoting him but when you see these
words written out versus how you hear
him talk about it in a one-on-one
private conversation yeah or public
conversation anyways because it's on a
podcast yeah it comes off way
differently yeah and I don't think a lot
of people did their due diligence to
actually see this clip or even listen to
the full podcast yeah so here we go
you love these movies these Marvel
movies I don't love them no I don't I
know I don't hate them all right but I
don't love them all right I mean look I
used to collect Marvel Comics like crazy
when I was uh a kid and so there's an
aspect that if these movies were coming
out when I was in my 20s I would totally
be [ __ ] happy and totally love them I
mean they wouldn't be the only movies
being made they would be those movies
amongst other movies
um but uh you know uh you know I'm
almost 60. so yeah no I'm not quite as
excited about them as I tell you the
thing I mean for me I don't have your
level of of knowledge of Cinema but as a
film go or somebody who likes movies I
mean
what's exciting about a movie is usually
some element of surprise right and what
you see what I've seen in a lot of these
films is that
it is just a carbon copy essentially of
the previous release like you you're
never taken somewhere you don't expect
in the film yeah well like I'm not here
to wrap my nose yeah you know so it's
like you know I I don't have it my only
axed grind against them is they're the
only things that seem to be made yeah
and they're the only things that seem to
generate any kind of excitement right
amongst a fan base or just or even like
uh for the studio making them all right
that's that's what they're excited about
true and uh you know so it's just the
fact that
that they are the they are the entire
representation
of this era of movies right now right
and there's not really much room for for
anything else that's my problem they do
like billion dollar box office I mean
yeah but that is that is literally my
problem it's a problem of representation
okay
um but uh uh you know but but to go back
to your initial question part of the
marvelization of Hollywood is yeah no
it's the um
you have all these actors who have
become famous playing these characters
but they're not movie stars right
Captain America is the star right Thor
is the star uh uh I mean I'm not the
first person to say that I think that's
been said a zillion times you know but
you know but it's like you know it's the
these these franchise characters that
become become a star uh personally I
mean this is my own thing it's just that
I I've gone to these movies and you just
go like yeah it's a it's another
it's just it's not that different from
the previous film there's just new
there's some new effects before though
okay you know okay here's a better way
to say it it's like you know before
um you know even 2005 2009 or something
like that
if an actor stars in a movie that does
as good as the uh the Marvel movies do
well that that guy's a new star sure
they're an absolute star and that means
that people did dig him or her yeah and
they like them and they want to see them
and stuff and then they you know uh
Sandra Bullock is in speed
right all right and everyone like
thought she was amazing in it all right
she was Charming as hell everyone fell
in love with her and so you know even
she does a couple of uh mediocre movies
after that the Nets and something else
okay well people went to see it because
they they were excited by Sandra Bullock
they want to see her in something else
and she's good in those movies yeah you
know but that's not the case now yeah
yeah it's not the case no no we want to
see that guy playing
so this is essentially what he was
saying right right which is kind of
interesting that he's kind of inner like
for for semen um oops my bad I call him
semen Lube
okay let's not start nothing all right
that was a complete accident yeah I
don't know why it came out yeah yeah I'm
really horny his name and his name was
very sexy yeah yes he has the nicest
Asian body in Hollywood yes gigantic
head we have it so the interesting thing
about this clip right when I when I
listened to it and what people were
saying about it for the people who were
very Pro simu about what he said was
that interestingly enough he's actually
fighting for the actor here yeah it's
actually like simu he's fighting for you
he's saying that the Marvel franchise
has become so strong that this is the
only representation of film in this era
of film right now yeah which it's a
representation issue okay aren't you
about representations
yeah so clearly he didn't watch this
clip as I'm watching it I'm trying to
figure out okay sumu where's your point
he's literally fighting for you he's
saying that he misses the era or he
believes that it should be a focus on
the actor and their skill level yeah he
didn't say that Marvel Marvel like
actors can't [ __ ] act is that now the
attention is I want to go see Thor I
want to go see Spider-Man instead of the
actor so he's actually fighting for you
you [ __ ] dummy
so like now I'm thinking about what are
you trying to say the bigger picture and
what you're projecting is that you're
brown nosing up to the Marvel overlords
because he's critiquing Marvel that's
more or less of how I can only interpret
this now you know it's like he's trying
to fight for your cause like yeah let's
see you in something outside of Shang
Chi right will that person in Iowa go
and see it because simulu is on the
movie poster or will that you see the
movie poster and say oh Chang ji's in
this movie yeah I'm gonna see it and
that's just really the point he didn't
say anything scathing at all yeah it was
just him talking about this state of
Hollywood yeah it's just the state of
Hollywood and how like things are being
taken away from a variety of a variety
of films that you can see and a lot of
the accolades are going to these billion
dollar films where people are just going
to see Thor and I'll be 100 honest with
you if you guys are out there you guys
know too I'm a part of that group I'm
not going to see [ __ ] Spider-Man to
see Tom Holland yeah I'm going to see
[ __ ] Spider-Man
[Laughter]
yeah there's a reason I still haven't
seen like any of his other movies
exactly I'm not saying any of his other
movies point in case right let's talk
about
um
Daniel Radcliffe Harry Potter Harry
Potter he's an amazing actor and he's
done a lot of great films even after
Harry Potter yeah here's the thing ask
me a film of that he's done after
so have you seen any films in Daniel
Radcliffe talk about Harry Potter what
yeah is what I'm saying right and he
recently did a film where he's playing a
skinhead and that was circulating around
and guess what the biggest [ __ ]
comment was it feels weird to see Harry
Potter use the n-word with a hard R
right yeah so even what's happening this
is what's happening he dove into a
character right he's playing this this
skin head yeah all they see is Harry
Potter and this is what he's talking
about when it comes to these franchises
which I agree a lot of actors agree you
know who else agreed if we're talking
about representation [ __ ] Anthony
Mackey hmm yeah I saw that clip did you
see that you saw that clip people will
go see movies just because they said
it's going to be number one
and everybody know the movie's bad
you know you'll read a review on Rotten
Tomatoes and be like oh they gave it you
know 75 Tomatoes it's fresh I should go
see it when they haven't even seen the
movie
you know so the the evolution of the
business has gone to like there are no
movie stars anymore like Anthony Mackie
isn't a movie star the Falcon is a movie
star
and that's what's weird it used to be
with Tom Cruise and Will Smith and
Stallone and Schwarzenegger when you
went to the movies you went to go see
the Stallone movie you went to go see
the Schwarzenegger movie now you go see
X-Men
so the the evolution of the superhero
has meant the death of the movie star
and that's the fear now because you're
now making movies for 16 year olds and
China
and that's it
you think of some of your favorite
movies growing up those movies wouldn't
get made today Goonies
wouldn't get made today Halloween
wouldn't get made today thing
wouldn't get made today wow and all of
them you watch you watch stranger things
on Netflix has anybody ever seen
stranger things
stranger things is Goonies
is everything it's it's Goonies
yeah
three kids go on a mission find
underground there's an alien kill alien
Goonies
even when they found the little dark
world where the alien was they went down
the slide like Goonies
so it's just it's a different time now
the business they make movies for a
specific audiences as opposed to just
making good movies and that's why people
stop going to the movies because most of
the movies suck
Anthony Mackey was saying what Quentin
Quentin Tarantino said but more scathing
way more harsh and he is a Marvel actor
he's a big franchise character he's
[ __ ] Captain America now yeah yeah so
how so simu you should tell him about
white ass Hollywood through this black
actor
I didn't like how he put race into it
again right it was very unnecessary
because that's not what he was talking
about yeah and he somehow brought race
back into it once again to glorify his
position as I am the hero of the race
Wars he wants that title so bad and I
don't give a [ __ ] with anybody else no I
do give a [ __ ] what you guys say I do
want to hear your opinions but do you
kind of understand what I'm talking
about now and why I don't dislike the
guy because I don't [ __ ] know him I
can't dislike somebody I don't know but
I can only talk about things in the way
that he represents himself and now
people are seeing through his charade
right the whole idea of this is for it
it's not for Asian people semen it's for
you we we know it now we get it now and
now people are seeing it and it's not
just me yeah right so I expect a lot of
apologies I expect a lot of like oh okay
I can kind of see what you're saying
once again not saying he's a bad person
but right now the the trick isn't
working buddy yeah look
um you you got into a huge movie right
and you're you're in the Marvel safety
net but then you say some [ __ ] to
Tarantino and [ __ ] Martin Scorsese
what any other Hollywood actor now want
to work with you
you know like like I'm not saying like I
oh like oh let's you know I hope it's
not like I really think that he should
succeed you know as the part of like you
know whatever roles he takes and stuff
I'm not rooting for him to fail you know
but it's like you know you step on a lot
of rakes bro
[ __ ] Homer Simpson over here dude
so somebody mentioned this to me too and
I actually found out about this because
I'm an actor friend of mine who messages
to me and he goes and he wrote to me he
goes my biggest
issue with simu is the fact that I don't
think he truly understands his position
in the acting world what have you done
to speak the way that you do
um Anthony Mackey said what he said look
at what Anthony Mackey has done yeah
right you did Kim's Convenience
and then you did uh shanxi right you
were nobody praised you on shangshi
because you were an amazing actor
because you delivered your lines amazing
you were actually pretty bad in terms of
the acting skill level right and
everybody can agree on that right most
people can
the beeline character which was Tony
lung was all people were talking about
when it came to acting delivering
emotions and what happened
so when you kind of put yourself and
then you go well you know as an actor
nobody looks at you like an actor yet
because you haven't earned that title
yet in terms of like you know you've
learned the title of being an actor but
the way that you speak about yourself is
as if you're Denzel you're not yeah
you're Chang Chi right now right let us
see a few more projects that you have so
you could really show your acting chops
as of right now nobody has seen it yeah
nobody has seen your acting chops
whatsoever you didn't have a lot of
great lines in this film to even be even
to like showcase what you can do all
right one of the one of the things I
hated in Shang Chi was that emotional
scene with him and and Anora what they
were staring off at that Lake yeah he
was supposed to emote and it was like a
robot talking yeah it was it was
terrible yeah so yeah and I'm not gonna
even say that's a representation of his
acting that might have just been bad
writing that was hard for him to do yeah
but a great actor can make poor lines
really amazing so I think for him like
just like my friends did who wrote this
he goes he doesn't understand his
position and he hasn't done the work yet
in terms of like in the world of acting
to even speak the way that he does this
podcast is brought to you by rocket
money do you know how difficult it is to
cancel a subscription or maybe you
forgot to cancel something and your
money just keeps on Flip Flip flipping
away out of your dang pocket every month
and you're like how am I so poor well
guess what that's where rocket money
comes in are you wasting money on
subscriptions 80 of people have
subscriptions they forget about maybe
for you it's an unused Amazon Prime
account or a Hulu account that never
gets streamed do you know how much
subscriptions really cost most Americans
think they spend around 80 a month on
subscriptions when the actual number is
close to 200 or more the app shows all
your subscriptions in one place and then
cancels for you whatever you still don't
want that is why I love me rocket money
my friends to cancel a subscription all
you have to do is press cancel and
Rocket money takes care of the rest get
rid of useless subscriptions with rocket
money now go to rocketmoney.com
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's rocketmoney.com genius
cancel your unnecessary subscriptions
right now at
rocketmoney.com genius
so it comes off as very condescending
for somebody who doesn't have that
position yet yeah and I say the word yet
because I don't know how far he can go
yeah right
he probably has a lot of other things
lined up so when this comes out and we
see the other films that you do and then
you don't match up to the [ __ ] that
you're talking we'll see what's up yeah
right and I'm not wishing for that I'm
wishing that the next project that you
do that you come out as an amazing actor
so you could talk that [ __ ] [ __ ]
because right now your foundation is
shaky that's why people every time you
tweet something about representation
people see through it now they go this
is not about representation this is
about you so the first thing they want
to tell you to do is shut the [ __ ] up
just be quiet yeah let your artwork let
your work show who you are you can do
that dude you can [ __ ] do it you can
let your work represent you rather than
your [ __ ] tweets and your [ __ ]
random rants that have nothing to do
with you yeah it's just just being
interjected into right yeah he just
wants to be like hey I I can say
something excuse me I'm here remember
you're not a Reddit in cell anymore yeah
there's no anonymity for you know about
these people before you go and say Well
they're the reasons why Hollywood is is
white as hell you're talking about
[ __ ] Martin scorsay the the guy who
has literally a program where he's
Reviving films from other countries
right now that haven't gotten any
Limelight because of the whitetization
of Hollywood he literally has something
right now a foundation that's providing
foreign films that people have not seen
because they were foreign films at the
time that people didn't want to see so
who the [ __ ] are you talking about right
now yeah I mean in in like the whole
thing with Martin Scorsese like the
thing he said was that Marvel films our
theme park like sorry
I'm sorry but he's not wrong though when
you walk into a Marvel movie now it's
not a like a story you know impacted
plot driven like kind of thing anymore
it is kind of like jumping on a roller
coaster yeah you know and look at this
too I'll give you another example of
what they're talking about Chadwick
Boseman right before he passed away he
did a film on Netflix it was supposed to
be some of his best acting that he's
ever done he did that while he had
cancer yeah nobody talked about it
what did they say when he passed away
there will never be another black
panther yeah they're not talking about
his acting skills and so in in a lot of
the stuff that he's done he's an amazing
[ __ ] actor and it takes a great actor
to play somebody like black panther
right so I don't think he's taking away
from the actor's skills he is talking
about the franchise and what the
franchise does to actors not that those
actors cannot act what are you talking
about yeah I mean like spoiler alert he
doesn't show up in Black Panther too you
know and there is no t'challa they
didn't recast him why
for the reverence of him the actor yeah
or you know they interjected the
situation of our real lives into the
story you know that's what it means you
know like that's up to the people but
man I don't know
you know I'm not I'm not saying I hope
you know anything bad happens to Seema
but if you were to go you know do you
think Nora would take up the shot she
crowds
10.
potatoes say you mean they're [ __ ]
platonic asexual relationships yeah
so I'm like come on man like even just
being a realist I don't think you're
there or we as Asian Americans are there
like within the culture but see this is
what I'm saying too and I'm
this is from a personal experience I've
had with them right so you know when I
reviewed the film right and then we we
also talked about him with the whole Bob
was it Bob chapek or chat pick yeah yeah
they just bounced him by the way I know
Bob anger just came back okay so you
can't correct us because
you know he talked about like oh this is
going to be an experiment because this
is the first time in since pandemic that
we've actually put out a film in
theaters yeah and this [ __ ] goes
off he goes we as Asian people are not
your experiment oh my oh my God this
isn't like like a Tuskegee thing bro
[Laughter]
so once again he did that again over
here he did it again yeah and now people
are seeing it they're like the first
time they're like oh I could see he
maybe he made that mistake right yeah
and then he did the thing with um uh
what's it called uh the Mandarin What's
that show called again Moonlight or no
Moonlight yeah Moon Knight Moon Knight
amazing film Moon Knight not so good
Moon Knight right where he was
criticizing
um uh Joaquin Phoenix saying that Ethan
huh Ethan Hawke in Phoenix I'm sorry
apologies Ethan Hawke he goes somebody
needs to fire his Mandarin coach because
he couldn't learn on this huge budget
film how to speak Mandarin I was like
you know I saw you on Kim's Convenience
you couldn't learn how to speak Korean
properly yeah
nobody's saying nothing nobody's saying
anything to you it's like hey man that's
like that's that's part of your
franchise man why are you criticizing it
yeah also like maybe we should [ __ ]
[ __ ] on Jackie Chan yeah his English is
still terrible yeah I mean he's been in
how many Hollywood films and he still
can't respect the American way by
learning how to speak proper English
yeah whatever what is your logic what
are you talking about like okay walking
I'm so sorry he couldn't learn this
[ __ ] tonal language this very
difficult tonal language and he couldn't
do it to your standards the next time I
speak to him you better speak flu you
better be fluent in [ __ ] Korean yeah
because you're on Kim's Convenience for
so many yeah you were representing my
culture what you don't speak Korean yeah
so I'm saying like there is no
foundation for the criticism that he's
taking like he's had Great Moments right
but now it's just like I think he's
sucking his dick so hard right now
because he enjoys being the the hero the
real life Asian hero that nobody asked
for you know why we recognize this
because
who amongst our acquaintances or the
people around us or even mutual friends
of the people we grew up with behaves
like that
the the guy who has some kind of weird
like victim complex like they're all out
to get me yeah like oh this guy tried to
step up to me and then like they like
tell this like elaborate thing as if
like people are out to get them and it's
like nah man the world is okay I mean
look I've I've been there in his shoes
though yeah and a lot of Asian men do
this too and it's not good and it's pop
part of that Asian Reddit in cell kind
of behavior right and it's like you know
it's not so much like like maybe you
should stop generalizing all these
people like for how they tell you about
the way you look and all these things
that go against I don't know yeah yeah
just basic your basic vanity which is
like some people need that [ __ ] you know
for their confidence and all those
things but I've been there like in high
school the hot blonde girl I was sitting
next to in keyboarding class told me I
like I was the ugliest guy in school
you know
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] you know and only like really
later like yeah I did understand like
yeah a lot of white people have been
told just Asian people are unattractive
right and that's something that's
learned or something
and you know what I just stopped getting
like I I don't know I didn't have that
resentment over them whatever that has
to deal with your own internal yeah and
the reason why I don't [ __ ] care is
because who are they did to describe
what attractive clearly we're doing fine
there's a billion of us yeah yeah
clearly we're [ __ ] oh did you hear
the news we just crossed 8 billion in
population on the earth well there it is
dude let's celebrate yeah there you go
and guess who's [ __ ] the most Asian
people Asian people so it's like even
that idea bothers me right it's like
Chinese people
like white people don't find us
attractive why do you want them to what
is this obsession with this this white
royalty bringing out their sword and
dabbing you on the shoulders and
knighting you as attractive why do you
need it so much why do you need that you
don't [ __ ] need it at all and by the
way that's like in this Locus to [ __ ]
America right because my friends who
live out in Europe they don't talk about
that [ __ ] yeah they don't mention that
[ __ ] at all that place is white as [ __ ]
that's the white Source yeah
that might be like a you thing right
because it's not a clear representation
of the rest of the world we have friends
in Europe who go like why is America so
obsessed with race like when we're here
we just date people right we [ __ ] first
and then we ask questions
okay yeah so you know listen like this
isn't like a [ __ ] party like [ __ ] on
simu type of party but you know I do
only want to talk about the things that
he has been doing that kind of represent
himself and I want him to understand
that you represent you you don't
represent all of us
right nobody asked you to take up this
chalice nobody asked you to go ahead and
be our quote-unquote Asian superhero
bear this cross yeah yeah because I have
to say something you know my Bobby Lee
populated representation man out there
or I just want to represent myself yeah
and then Mike this is this is like my
biggest advice to a lot of people who
ask me this they go like how do you feel
about you representing um like your
culture I don't represent my culture I
represent myself right yeah and if you
like my culture because I have carried
myself well then I've done my job yeah
my mission isn't to go be like here I'm
Korean I'm Korean just turn people off
yeah I am Korean that is who I am this
is what I represent I don't have to
shove it in your [ __ ] face it's like
the idea of like people who are
religious zealots and how they turn
people off by shoving their religion in
their face yeah if you are a good person
you are a reflection of the beliefs that
you have and people feed off of that
[ __ ] yeah same thing with my culture
people will be curious about Korean
people because they're curious about me
because they [ __ ] with me I don't have
to go ahead and wave this huge Korean
flag because accordion never us for
people to respect that and I don't think
that he's at that place he has a lot of
like personal trauma that he's dealing
with that he's projecting it out to
other people in a terrible way I mean
like you you brought up Bobby Lee like
he for the Asian American Community like
Bobby Lee's up there you know yeah like
he's a I think he's a goat you know yeah
or what he's done like but then
um if look if you look at Bobby Lee and
think he represents all Asian people
then you're a piece of [ __ ] you know he
does not he does not he represents Bobby
Lee he's so very uniquely Bobby Lee yeah
you know and he does not even claim to
represent all of us nor does I don't
believe he wants to right yeah like he
always hear these weird conversations
too from a lot of like people who are in
this space and they're just like yeah
you know as somebody who's like in this
entertainment space he's like listen I
know you nobody has ever asked you to be
in a movie you suck you're not a part of
this conversation at all whatsoever yeah
like who what are you talking about like
well you know when we come in you know
as somebody who's an Asian and
entertainment you are not an
entertainment you want to be an
entertainment you are not a part of this
conversation I'm not a part of this
conversation so when you talk about
acting roles that you're auditioning for
for stuff that you've never auditioned
for shut up
be quiet
yeah like you know who the [ __ ] they are
yeah two brothers
man you know God that I mean that always
like follows me because you know
especially in LA or wherever I go
you know like I'm from Seattle and like
oh do you know those guys and I'm like
like comes up every single [ __ ] time
and I'm just like you know let me just
like I don't know like just I have I
have other interesting things to talk
about please hey big blessings to them
or whatever you know everybody follows
me everywhere I go you know it's just I
I don't want people to be in this space
of like following his example and how
he's carrying himself right as somebody
who is an Asian American in like social
media or whatever what not I don't know
how long I'm going to be on the space
which is partially the reason I don't
give a [ __ ] about what I say on this
podcast I don't know how long I'm going
to be on here I don't care about this
[ __ ] I'm just the most regular [ __ ]
person you'll ever meet in your life
yeah and I say things on this podcast
that a lot of you [ __ ] say at home a
lot of you have these conversations but
you're so scared about not having
opportunities because you don't want to
say the wrong thing because one day you
might [ __ ] meet this person they
might give you an opportunity [ __ ] those
people be who you are say how you
[ __ ] feel and be an honest human
being and you will find your own [ __ ]
path you're like have some [ __ ] I
don't know a backbone yeah have some
[ __ ] have some balls I don't know like
I I just don't understand listen I'm
glad people are seeing it right I'm not
glad that he's carrying himself in the
way that he has yeah I wish well upon
I'm not just saying that [ __ ] just
because I can criticize somebody for the
[ __ ] that they've done it doesn't mean
I'm wishing on their downfall I'm
wishing for him to be the next biggest
star where he could really show his
[ __ ] acting chops or I can see him be
in a film standing next to amazing
actors and not be [ __ ] overshadowed
by their acting skills I want him in
that role because then he'll actually
have some [ __ ] to say but I guarantee
you if he was doing that he wouldn't
have said what he said if he really
liked film he wouldn't have been saying
that to Tarantino Scorsese yeah
somebody would have asked him
I don't know Access Hollywood extra
extra they would have asked him what he
thought if it was relevant to him yeah
they would have been like him Z would
have called him up and somebody would
somebody would have right and he's just
like as an actor it's like okay buddy as
a movie star as a movie star remember
you're not you know Denzel all right not
yet anyways you have time he might be
amazing and I'm and I'm gonna [ __ ]
root for him and watch you just watch
you watch where he comes out with the
film when he's dope and see if I don't
[ __ ] give him his praise I'm gonna
give him his [ __ ] praise yeah I'm a
I'm a listen I've had conversations with
with uh Nora and she's she's so [ __ ]
funny to me right she comes up to me she
goes
do you do you hate me
I was like no I [ __ ] love you I [ __ ]
with that girl so heavy she goes oh I
wasn't sure like blah blah blah because
like she was like I told them to
introduce me to you a while ago he never
has
and you know for her and I was telling
her too and we had this conversation
it's like just because I don't like
everything that you do doesn't mean that
I [ __ ] I'm not supporting and
watching everything that you do in a
positive way yeah I was like when I saw
you at the farewell I was instantly a
fan of you for life because I knew that
the level of skill and acting that you
have is is honestly above a majority of
the people that I've seen on screen like
people don't ever give her her Duke they
give her like that do credit of being
that quirky weird Asian girl no she can
[ __ ] act her [ __ ] ass off dude I
[ __ ] with that girl so [ __ ] heavy
dude she has my support for life
um does that mean that I enjoy
everything she does no no I think that
she was good in Shang Chi no yeah I mean
the problem is like look we're in La
everything is so binary it's thumbs up
or thumbs down it's rotten or fresh yeah
you know it's like hey you had some hit
and misses do you like baseball dude if
you have a 300 average that means if you
hit like yeah like a third of the balls
in Major League Baseball you're a
[ __ ] star and you'll make 30 million
dollars a year that means you fail a lot
of times and you strike out all a lot of
times yeah you know but then the fact is
they live with it like with like what
they are but then people I swear in La
they just hot and cold on and off when
because people you know can accept and
see the positive comments out there
right they don't realize that those
negative comments like will affect you
the exact same way you know they're the
same thing and I guarantee you
um once again this is speculation
people around him sing his Praises a
little too much
and you know when you are in that
position and somebody for him you know
seemingly most likely you're never going
to listen to this
um and if you are listening to this you
should get a life bro we don't listen to
this but no but in all honesty no
because that reminds me of like you know
I live in K-Town for a while and like I
just go down to bars and whatever just
walk around and I'm not gonna say which
one but I'd see a member of The Black
Eyed Peas I bet you've seen him too I
know you're Dumbo he's just hangs around
and you can tell he's just waiting for
someone to talk to him right
it got weird for a while yeah you just
see him like every weekend but this is
what I'm saying like I think he's
getting to that point now where you know
Notice Me notice me like also too for
him it's just you got to understand
buddy people around you are going to
just Echo everything that you feel
because they want to be on your good
side like who are your friends that you
have that you've known since you were a
kid that you were younger that could
actually tell you what's up yeah if you
don't have that then you're not gonna
you're gonna keep making these stupid
decisions and choices because they're
just going to keep championing you every
time you do something dumb they're going
to be like yeah you're right you're
right they're not going to be like bro
that was dumb
growing up I had Youngs who would
[ __ ] slap me on my lips if I said
something [ __ ] you know but honestly we
need those people in our lives yeah you
know I have a bunch of those [ __ ]
people in my lives right and they always
be like hey man that's a bit much oh bro
chill with that type of [ __ ] and I go oh
[ __ ] my bad and I get corrected I
guarantee you nobody saying that [ __ ] to
him and I know this because after we did
our last podcast this will DM me and
then he was like I just want to let you
know that we're cool and I'm like all
right if you don't have like cool for
what yeah personal problems yeah even
beyond that
I don't give a [ __ ] who are you
who are you to me I just want to let you
know we're cool all I and I I did
something very nice I just said hey man
you got a lot of heat on your shoulders
right now and I just wish the best for
you that's all I said what I wanted to
say was
I don't give a [ __ ] what you think I do
a podcast [ __ ] and you were a Hot Topic
yeah that's all that it is
hey man your [ __ ] got like 70 000 likes
I think we're entitled to talk about it
yeah
and I'll tell you this too if shangshi
did terrible in the box office right
yeah I probably wouldn't have done the
the review that we did yeah that's salt
on the wounds and then we gotta pick up
our pupils right exactly I guarantee you
if shangshi did terrible I wouldn't have
done a review for it because whatever
has been said has been said yeah this
one was more like oh it made like almost
a like a half a billion dollars no
matter what I say it did well so let me
tell you how I feel dude I just watched
one of my friends films on Netflix
terrible and I literally in my head I
have 4 000 notes to why this is a bad
film do you think I'm gonna do a review
on it absolutely not yeah why should I
yeah it's already getting chewed up in
[ __ ] Rotten Tomatoes so it's like
there's no point so you know if anybody
who thinks that I'm just hating just
hate no it's not I think I give very
good valid points uh especially when it
comes to a topic like this I think that
once again I'm going to root for him
because I'm always going to root for
people who represent us yeah but
not everything that you do when you [ __ ]
up I'ma say some [ __ ] about it just like
everybody else does everybody is just so
good at pretending that they're [ __ ]
perfect yeah you know nobody wants to
show their [ __ ] flaws yeah I got a
flaws I mean like if you can say your
own [ __ ] out loud then it it's a it's
way more comfortable just say other [ __ ]
you know it's like dude that's some
[ __ ] right there you can call it out
yeah man I mean it's just such a weird
situation too like a lot of people are
acting like [ __ ] doesn't stink yeah
pretty much it's like come on man like
nobody wants to say what should be said
and everybody wants to say things that
they feel that other people will give
them a round of applause for and that's
how what we see on Twitter right now
that's what Elon Musk is fighting for
that is what Elon Musk is fighting for
right and listen I've been on Twitter
and I kind of miss like the old days of
Twitter where it was just kind of more
fun videos but now it's just everybody
has a political opinion about everything
yeah and how I see it from my
perspective is that you know none of you
actually have to be on this app nobody's
forcing you you can just knock me on it
you know they're like this is my right
no you could just not be on it or how
about you celebrities that say
[ __ ] this app I'm out how about don't
tweet five seconds after you tweet that
yeah
but you're still there yeah
I'm the I'm the [ __ ] lurker on
Twitter I don't I never post [ __ ] yeah
on Twitter but then I look around and
see what's going on that's for sure you
know the funny thing is like we all come
running back to see if it's gonna
[ __ ] fail now with everything that's
going on dude man my favorite Twitter
account I ever Fool's gone wild food's
gone wild it's just so funny dude I I've
seen their stuff on Instagram yeah the
the high stock checks yeah people yeah
okay yeah who's gone wild is hilarious
but like Twitter is kind of a
representation of how people are in this
in this city you know
um or how I feel anyways and not talking
about people who grew up in La I'm
talking about people who come to the
city thinking that they have to be
something that they're not and they play
this caricature 24 [ __ ] seven and
they try to latch onto certain ideals
because they know that in Liberal ass
Hollywood
um and by the way I'm pretty liberal
myself but like in Liberal ass Hollywood
if they don't follow suit or they don't
question anything that they'll get the
pat on the back like opposing thoughts
now are not allowed and is considered
you being uh what's it called uh
oppressive if you ask questions oh my
gosh I have a [ __ ] story about that
so like back in the day I was out and I
got some bar with the girl and then we
went to
um sundubuji K-Town uh uh I know what
you're talking about yeah the one that's
open 24 7. PCD
so um you know at like 2 A.M BC is
[ __ ] packed like to the gills and um
sitting there looking at the menu and
then I hear this clanging and banging
just
like someone's playing drums with their
Chopsticks right and I got so annoyed
that I walked over to the table and I
went to the guys and I was like hey man
you know I just want to say like
normally like we don't we don't play
drums with our Chopsticks you guys are
in K-Town right now like can you guys
cut it out please yeah you know it's
really rude you know and then one guy
with the beard he was like a giant I
think
we're sorry we're sorry yeah and I was
like okay and I went back uh to my table
and then all of a sudden I feel this
hand like when I'm sitting down that
walking by me he grabs my [ __ ]
shoulders and he squeezes it right and
he gets down in my ear in the back of my
ear he's like come outside I want to
talk to you
right and then I'm literally like that
just that did not just happen right now
yeah right and he came back he said come
outside I'm gonna talk to you it's like
all right then [ __ ] it like I went
outside uh we're in front of the front
doors of BCD and he's like look man
I'm from Eagle Rock okay
I'm a Democrat you know I'm part of the
occupied movement movement all right bro
and I was like yeah cool dude you know
what I love Denny's I don't go over
there and play drums with my spoon and
fork yeah you know like
cool dude like I lean left too but like
you are [ __ ] embarrassing me right
now like
he thought that I was saying he was a
racist or something like no you're being
a [ __ ] infant toddler yeah I cut it
out but that's the weird thing too like
I don't people don't even know how to
argue on the same page yeah they don't
even know how to position themselves
correctly in a conversation you know why
because it was a personal offense it's
because of the way you heard it and you
took it and the way it deals with your
trauma and your past and what triggers
you and now they have to apologize for
some [ __ ] they don't know anything about
it's just a weird thing like I I don't
care to have these type of conversations
anymore and I was telling um Ed off
camera too about the story where there
was this guy that I had a conversation
with where
we are talking about like political
views and I don't care to talk about
politics because I don't know anything
about politics right but I do ask a lot
of questions especially when it comes to
topics I don't [ __ ] know about and
one of the things that I dislike and
it's probably because I grew up in a
house where everything was you were told
something just because without any
[ __ ] reasoning and you just had to
believe it because I said so because I
said so so when people say because I
said so to me it's a trigger for me yeah
in the sense of
it's almost like you're being very
dismissive of the things that I'm asking
right and if I ask a question it means
that I'm talking down to you which is
dumb a question is a [ __ ] question
especially if I'm asking it nicely yeah
so
you know with this person they were
talking about their political views and
they were like [ __ ] all Republicans
um because I'm a Democrat and I was like
what do you mean [ __ ] all Republicans
and I was like okay dude uh what do you
mean by that and he goes well because
they're hyper intolerant and I just
think that if you're if you are a
registered Republican you're clearly a
terrible person because of you're rep
you're a part of a party and what they
represent I was like okay I'm pretty
moderate you know but I I lean left
um I don't think that's really fair
because we know the things that you are
saying about this party they kind of say
the same things about you so it just
seems like it's you guys are two extreme
ends of the spectrum and they go well
that's not fair because they are making
fun of us for being the tolerant left
and saying that we're intolerant
but we're intolerant of their
intolerance and I'm like okay this is a
circular argument that yeah like there's
no foundation for this like where are
you taking this yeah and I asked him I'm
like okay
the only issue that I see about this is
like why is it that you get to Define
what intolerance is on very specific
subjects like what do you consider
intolerant and they go well they don't
think that they they don't believe in
trans rights I was like all people all
Republicans yeah every I was like you
know political parties are more than
just social ideals
like most of the stuff that people
should care about is when it comes to
politics is where their money goes where
their dollar goes what happens in the
society like you're talking about like
social ideas which is a huge part of it
of course but there's another Spectrum
to it right you know not everybody who
voted for Trump was uh so was a racist
yeah right I know people who are Asian
and black that voted for Trump yeah so
when we had this conversation and you
start using these blanket terms
Republican Eagles racist they don't care
about human rights I was like all
Republicans are like that right
I was like I think that's a very bad
thing for you to do go ahead and blanket
this whole group and so I kind of broke
it down I was like okay and essentially
what got to this person too was that I
asked him I was like you know you
remember BLM right he's like were you
for or against it bills I was four BLM I
was like what was the biggest issue that
a lot of people have when they talk
about Black Culture I was like because
what
because what they see on social media
which is what you're saying is that the
things that you are seeing about
Republicans what you read on Twitter
Facebook and social media right yeah
what is Facebook and social media say
about black people
not great criminals yeah stupid idiots
uneducated animals that's right [ __ ]
so if everything online is true then I
guess what they say about
black Americans are true then too right
yeah and that person was dead quiet I
was like you are basing what you believe
on what you've read on headlines
um when you don't want that stuff to be
done to you this is the problem that we
have here like
you are so la
yeah and what I mean by that is not
native La people I'm talking about you
have taken this Cross of like hyper
liberalism just because it's cool and
you have nothing to add to the
conversation right because you literally
sound like Twitter headlines
and yeah me
and when I ask you why I could already
tell in your tone with the way you're
talking to me you're pissed I was like
why are you pissed I was like let me ask
you something what do you think my
political party is right she's like well
clearly from the way you're talking
you're Republican I was like I'm a rich
Democrat crazy yeah you didn't know the
person's dead quiet and I've never ever
talked about like what my political
party but I'm a registered Democrat I
was like you didn't even know I'm
left-leaning yeah I just asked you
questions and you got [ __ ] mad yeah
about stuff that you don't know about
you're angry because you don't have the
answers and you could have simply just
said I don't know
like how weird is that type of [ __ ] and
I'm not saying that most guys are like
this it's like or most people that you
meet are going to be like this but I
think like this person had a very good
learning moment right where they kind of
understood like oh I he was just asking
questions and I got mad at him and I was
being very [ __ ] civil this doesn't
happen a lot because like I said usually
when I ask people questions
they know that it's just out of
curiosity and they'll be able to explain
themselves right because even more even
more so this was like you know an hour
conversation at a copy spot and it was
like
we talked about she want uh he wanted to
talk about like a trans rights right
right and he was like well they don't
believe that trans people should have
rights and I'm like
who is they yeah
all people who are Republican believe
that or the people that you see online
and it's like do you see what I'm saying
right now and they and this is the part
where the conversation got weird because
they said and I told this this guy said
well trans people are the way that it's
science right and I was like okay and
once again I don't know anything about
the subject right I haven't spoken to a
trans person about this and I was like
cool what is the science and they go
it's just science and I'm like
that's not what I'm asking I'm asking
you you just said it's something but
what is the science like I'm curious
it's like she's retweeting the tweets
she saw back at you in real life that's
what she was trying to do yeah it's like
dude it's just science I'm like okay guy
do you understand how bad this
conversation is going now yeah like I'm
curious about something and you just
said something like it's science and I'm
like
yeah but what is the science though like
I wanna I wanna know I want to learn
what you're talking about and probably
somebody in the comments could probably
elaborate on on what this guy was trying
to say but
um that was such a bad conversation for
me yeah especially if you really want to
know yeah right and that person did the
just because they shut up and just
listened to me yeah and it's like that
is not being a good representative of
like being an ally I guess you would say
right yeah to be like okay but like I'm
here to be educated right now it's like
well you don't know no more yeah it's
like my parents yeah you don't know yeah
you don't know the circumference of the
earth
like no I don't [ __ ] know dude yeah
so can you please enlighten me as I'm
trying to have a civil conversation like
I'm like it knows like we're both very
curious people like we're just gonna ask
yeah and if somebody asking you offends
you then you got a problem yeah you have
a real big issue that means you do not
know how to have a conversation at all
if you think that somebody asking you a
question about a topic that you brought
up that you're supposed to be well
versed at is an issue yeah that's you
dude
talk to me like that man yeah and it's
like of course like I'm not gonna go and
tell this guy's name on the podcast I'm
not going to do any of that type of
stuff but at the same time hopefully
he's going to like reevaluate how he has
conversations with people or at least be
well versed because we talk about this
in like religion I can't sit around here
and be like dude
what does the scripture say about that
and they go and then somebody asked me
what does the scripture say and I go you
don't know yeah
so read the Bible
yeah yeah you've got a hair yeah you
don't know about God yeah that's the
problem man I would never do that you
know
such a weird conversation so this this
past week has been just odd you know
what I'm saying yeah
but anyways guys
like an hour
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast uh you could
find Ed at edpark v p he just finished a
new podcast after three years yeah
finally picking it up no yeah so
breakfast at Momo's is the podcast you
guys could go ahead and check out his
podcast Bible study I'm sorry breakfast
and the paper
Bible study at Momos yeah you can go
ahead and check that out once again if
you guys are tuning into this and you
listen to this whole podcast and you
love simulu you probably already moved
on oh it's coming man oh it's coming I
already feel it yeah but just to let you
know I actually support him a hundred
percent it's like
come on we're being like come on man
yeah you can do better for sure yeah you
could 100 do better man like like I said
the next film that he's out that he's
going to be in outside of uh Shang Chi
I'm gonna watch that [ __ ] and I'm gonna
watch it and watch it we're gonna see
how good his acting chops are and I
don't mean that in a bad way like I I
think because he's talking so big I'm
pretty sure it's gonna be it's gonna be
way different than you've ever seen him
in anything before but somebody just has
to give him a chance and I want to see
that [ __ ] when he gets those great lines
I want to see him [ __ ] deliver yeah
yeah I'm a simulu supporter so am I
[ __ ] weirdo
Jesus Christ Sunday's at 12 pm genius
brain bye bye